firstest
[Music]
02 no
[Applause]
here
[Music]
get
back
[Music]
further
fucking
out what do you say your best approach
is from the
[Applause]
back fire
request headquarters get us some more RS
here get B here
also the intersection of River Road
on with stay in your
vehicle back in your
car drunk no I'm the captain huh I'm the
captain a what
captain of what the big don't reach in
your pocket get back in your
car 116 Shel me 106 Henry Lincoln Edward
497 have a seat I will I'm
[Music]
not you've been drinking tonight I just
got a ride you've been drinking tonight
sir I'm a captain on a police department
what Police Department Oklahoma
City what division
[Music]
investigations what are you doing
pulling in here my mom and I St here you
been
[Music]
drinking how much we had to drink
tonight
sir please huh turn the camera off I'm
not turning my camera off okay go ahead
and step out of the vehicle
you got to be kidding
me yeah we're not going to get a return
on
it how much we drink tonight sir I was
at a poker game uh-huh Cuz you're were
swerving all over when you turn off you
didn't use your signal I'm
sorry how much did you drink at your
poker game not much not much how much is
not much I don't know beer liquor how
many many
beers three or four three or four how
long ago was
that it's been going on a
while how long ago did you drink your
last beer
sir what time is it
now it's
midnight you think you should driveing
no but I came from four blocks your mom
your mom lives here I live here you live
here
yes car like that a gun or anything I
don't even have a gun I'm 19 years old
I this problems and the trucks over
there I I'm just going to take out the
vest and I'm from Tennessee so okay why
are you wearing the vest like I said I
drove from all the way from Tennessee
but I'm not going to I'm not going to
have people call me when I don't even
live in this damn State it's going to
piss me off you're you're a deputy
sheriff well I mean I work at the
Sheriff's Office okay I mean what were
you a corrections officer for the
Sheriff's Office okay why do you wear a
vest outside of the
facility is this a agency vehicle or is
this your personal vehicle this is my V
okay it's just a little odd cuz whenever
I worked in the jail I took my crap off
especially if I was taking a long drive
from Tennesse what I said man if I if I
work guys the same thing I have been
pulled over so many times in Tennessee
and Arkansas okay they know I have told
them every single that might be true but
P before too wearing this stuff I mean
like it it every time I come up here I
mean like they don't all they say is
it's just odd I never see it I was like
well I mean like well guess what I like
wearing it just like in Tennessee I've
got pulled up for it and guess what yeah
I'm not saying it's against the law or
anything it's just and I've even had it
tooken off and I've had it set right
here before and they're like and I get I
get yelled at before they was like well
it's kind of weird that you got your
belt and your bedro you got any kind of
employment identification dude they
don't give me that when you work at the
deal really you don't have like an
access card or ID badge or anything for
the facility that you work at I don't I
can I can show you my
face that help think
of
thing on mine I mean oh so my only deal
is when you wear County there you go
yeah are you commissioned to carry a
gun um no I'm not not okay I don't even
have a gun on me well you realize
wearing the sheriff on your
chest is basically impersonating law
enforcement whether or not you're
carrying a
gun okay but are you commissioned to be
carrying a gun and you have arrest power
don't what do you mean I don't even
have that's beside the fact you're
wearing a patch that says Sheriff okay I
that's impersonating law enforcement
I've wore it all the time at the jail
before though okay well that might be
true and fine within the jail but when
you come out to public you don't have
any arrest Powers you don't you're not
commissioned I'll do you understand I
understand that I don't understand what
and you got alcohol in the vehicle well
it's not mine well that's beside the
point it's my girlfriend and I don't
drink so it doesn't it doesn't matter
you realize transporting open container
if any of that's opened or partially uh
missing that it doesn't matter whose it
is if you're in the vehicle with it you
can be arrested for uh transporting open
container well I mean like I said it's
it's it's not I
literally she bought it you she lives
over there in Luther have you ever heard
the phrase of when guys get hemmed up
for drugs in their pockets and they say
these pants aren't mine you realize how
I clear traff
9 okay so let's let's stop saying it all
right understand I problem I want to go
on my way I'm not from here so all
right all right tell me exactly what you
just said cuz he was dressed like a cop
he had a Sheriff thing but it had
Sheriff written on the side R right and
I live off 62 off Adam Road he was
sitting in a driveway
251 right beside 62 Highway and I pulled
up and I was staring at him because he
was in there kind of to and I was like
we live on one one way in one way out
and you know we we always are watching
for cars and I sit there I was staring
at him and I st about 10 minutes staring
at him and I'm like who the heck is this
guy it's kind of OD and our neighbor's
driveway I sat there and stared at him
stared at him and I drove off he got
right behind me and start followed mhm
and uh he's driving along he was right
on my right on me and I like me a this
is from over by the ha from there all
the way to Sonic all the way Sonic and
haris and I pulled in Sonic he pulled in
behind me he gets out and I said can I
help you sir he's like well uh I was
wondering what what was your problem you
were staring at me over in the in the
driveway and I said yeah I was kind of
curious who you was because that's kind
of odd that uh I didn't know who you was
I was kind of curious I live down the
show I was kind to see what was going on
and I was staring at you to see who you
was he goes I'm a I'm a uh undercover
cop for welon and I run my partner I run
with the H patrolman out of
welston okay and I said so uh just be
curious uh you look pretty young how old
are you it was only 22 years old just
turned 22 I was like I a pretty young be
a cop be an investigator right and uh I
said uh what brings to be a cops is it
like the family or whatever you know try
to just talk to him and he go yeah lot
of my family for cops and stuff and
that's I became cop I was
18 and then uh he goes uh well I got a
call I got to let you go and then he
left and then when he left he came
towards uh by the uh Bridge of on uh
Turnpike bridge and he took UI and was
trying to pull another car he was trying
to flash his lights at him really and I
I didn't know if if they pulled over or
not but he was flashing his lights like
he TR pull him over I was like that's
kind of strange right I got home as
while AG go told my wife I was like man
this car pulled me over and I was
talking to this guy and I was trying to
see it oh he did because we got a cop
friend that lives in Wellston I'm going
to call him later on when he wakes up to
see cuz I he works Night Shift to see if
he's really that guy really a cop just
odd how he was acting I got you can you
hang out here for a minute yeah all
right don't go nowhere okay all
right all right did you hear all that
yeah so y'all want
him that happened out in town you do
that true okay yeah so it's going to be
our it didn't happen in choc tall so but
yeah all right we're
taking
first we already know I'm going to all
right turn around face the other way put
your hands behind your
back you're under arrest for
impersonating law enforcement all right
and then you also have a charge for
transporting an open
container my girlfriend could pick up my
pH uh not at this
time you know how long I'm going to be
in jail
because
okay well your mom lives here so I'm not
too worried about that I
mean all right go ahead and step on out
I'm going to double check make sure you
don't have anything in your pockets or
no I'm
sorry we discovered a dead baby in the
bathroom oh my gosh I'm sorry he came
out in me and I didn't know what to do
Lexi I told you about
this I just asked you baby to tell me
the truth
SC was not
crying what did you do to it okay stop
right here stop stop number one priority
guys number one priority is she just had
a baby I don't know if she's delivered
the placenta she's bleeding
significantly yeah I've spoken to the
obstetrician at Loveless they want her
up there as soon as possible we need I
need your obviously need your permission
to transfer her from medical to she
she's 19 oh you're right but she is a
student
too you're right you're right she needs
to I'm sorry I forgot
she's you need to for to make sure that
you're safe I need to send you to
Loveless to labor
delivery will you please agree to that
yes yes great I'm going to work on that
um in terms I'm sorry about this but in
terms of delivering um a baby and it
looked like you tried to hide it we do
have to have the police
involved and that thing was crying it
came out with that thing I know I know
but the the baby's going to have to be
taken for autopsy and they'll be an
investigator and everything I'm really
sorry guys
I'm
sorry I'm so sorry that we need to do
this
correctly um and I want to be
transparent with you about what our
steps are going to be
okay Officer do you need to do you guys
need to talk to her before we get her
transferred how long is it going to be
before you have the transfer I don't
know working on Okay Marina do you think
20 30 minutes yeah hopefully yes I got I
got detectives on the way so they're
going to be talking for okay
do you guys have I'm the charge nurser
do you guys have any questions for me
like how big is the baby it's full term
what 9 months nothing was
crying let's see have you watched the
news of the girls that what they do to
their babies and what they go to jail
was
crying
[Music]
49 arriving we got to block the
intersection anyone inside the vehicle I
oh no I don't
[Music]
okay control 449 the vehicle is
completely on fire we cannot tell
[Music]
hey who was on this
vehicle I know this is completely on
fire put out the fire I know somebody
proba in there but this right here this
right
here come
be
[Music]
on hey let
me let me do something I don't think
someone's going to be there I'm no okay
what I need
to yeah what I need now they need
medical right here uh let me get tape
fucking block this intersection real
quick
yeah hey we got medical coming up okay
he needs medical right hold
on over
[Music]
there
1449 so we got more units coming here
help us with the
[Music]
[Applause]
traffic
kly come on in here and have a seat a
second I'm going to visit with you all
right so um just observing you in
classroom it looks like something's off
a little bit and so I've asked uh
officer Dean to come in here and visit
with it have you you know um have you
taken anything
that's you know do you have a
prescription for anything that maybe you
have taken today that just seems like
you're not the same person that I talked
to this morning um I did take a I I did
take some medication last night to to
help me with sleep because I have some
anxiety stuff but
that's
that's I can't think of the name of it
right now but I could look it up when I
get home okay so you haven't taken
anything while you were at school no
okay um
now one thing I would tell you is um you
know um for your employment I want you
to be truthful and so um would you um be
willing to take a breathalizer
test if I needed to yeah
okay you don't have to but if you're
willing to do it that helps
us have you taken any sort of medication
today I'm sorry what have you taken any
medication today I did take some
medication this morning for my anxiety
what did you take this morning
um I think it's called
um um
quen I'm not I'm not very good with that
did you take it here at
school I took it yeah I took it this
morning wait you're
here yeah right before I came in
yes please please tell me so that we can
we can help
you I mean I am having I I am having a
hard time with some depression stuff and
I I
um did you drink something while you
were here at
school not while I was at
school when did you drink something last
night
okay not here at school because it
seemed that it CH I mean your demeanor
kind of changed
changed anything here at
school oh I wouldn't bring it into the
school okay are you going to blow double
zeros I don't know you should know if
you had drank anything you should blow
zeros if you drank something recently
it's going to show
it just find
out
you going to tell me the truth how much
you had to drink what I drank last night
there's no way you drank last night well
I did drink last night did you drink at
school is what he's asking tell us a I
didn't drink at school that wouldn't
blow that right there you blew two times
the legal limit I did yeah here's our
drink that you had what's in this drink
that's a Diet Coke is there anything
liquor in it
nope so if I go into the classroom am I
going to find anything
else stand up stand up can you just no I
said I'm done no just no can I just walk
out without the hand one no please just
let me walk out with no it's
policy I'm not going to I'm not I'm
going to Cuff you up front if you're
going to keep running your mouth you're
going to get cuffed behind you wait can
I just talk to you for a second
please please don't put your hands
behind your back no I don't want to you
want to go to jail with multiple charges
no put your hands behind your back
please don't do this please I just want
to talk to you can you just talk to me
put your hands behind your
back please will you just please talk to
me I we've I've tried talking to you
will you you're you're not talking to me
now it talking's
over what about my stuff it'll go with
you to the
Jil I'm so sorry I'm so come come here
I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry we're just going to
put handcuffs on just for now sorry
pant where's I'm sorry I don't know what
the I'm so sorry sorry please I'm so
sorry I'm sorry I love you you better
pretty C fucking I'm s mom I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry how old are you I'm 12
years old where's the
knife it was upstairs in my room and I
threw it out the window and it's behind
the apartment right here you threw it
where I threw it out my window upstairs
not not right there it's the room this
the other room it's right behind the
apartment this apartment right here so
where would the knife be on that side
behind right behind the knife I'm so
fucking sorry Mama I'm so sorry I don't
know what happened this some demonic
shit I'm so sorry what's your mom name
what's your mom's
name I got to go with him I'm so sorry I
don't know what the happened I don't
know what happened I don't know what
happened you come over here so we're out
of the paramedics way know what
I'm so sorry hey what's your
name seat for me so criss cross on the
grass okay okay just sit there for a
second you don't have the knife on you
right no I swear I don't I'm sorry I
don't I don't I'm
sorry I don't know what
[Music]
happened come on come on
myig I can't believe they tell you she
don't my wife please she don't got to
hold the building she don't got to hold
the building it's respect it's respect
respect respect respect you don't bring
somebody that don't rock with the the
act the main act you don't bring
somebody here that rock with the m don't
do
thatd get him out of here get that
mother out back get out of here get him
out of camera man get him out of
here here relax relax we take care of
get him out of here right
now he's on the way get him out of here
right now he's going oh it's going to be
a Royal Rumble come on
man you're on the good
side you looking at hey you're you're on
the good side
look you don't
trouble
hey you don't do that don't you touch me
I don't
care white man don't you touch me don't
you touch
me
y'all want to kill
me got you
yougot I
got
you you gay you gay if you kill me you
all going to die nobody wants to hurt
you if you kill me Cracker you're going
down no wants to hurt you cracker
cracker you're going down first you
going that first
my let's
go okay so so what's going on this
morning so for the last three weeks
maybe longer she's had her couple's trip
plan with her boyfriend to go to Key
West okay but she just said you're going
that was the Key West I'm taking my kids
my three boys to the Bahamas this
morning our kids our
kids yesterday she send a message saying
that she's going to change her plans and
now get on the airplane with me and the
kids to go to Bahamas but I own too by
way we land she's going to go her
boyfriend elsewhere and me and the kids
are going to our house and I told her
I'm not supporting that and you're not
getting on the airplane that can mess
with the kids' heads and it's just
something we're not going to do well own
% of an
airplane she on paper owns 25 of that
and majority owner owner the other 50%
owner and myself are both in agreeance
to not have her on the airplane so 75%
says we don't want you on the
that doesn't mean you get aggressive
push me out of the way start unloading
my car push you out of the
way yes at the back of the
car okay Lind I did not push you or
anything he doesn't want me to go I
raised the back to grab my kids
suitcases with a locked car so we could
leave all it
is okay I'm gonna tell you both like I
told you a minute ago y'all have file
for divorce okay in situations like this
the best thing that we always recommend
is y'all separate don't just separate
from each other you don't need to be
going on vacation together if you file
for divorce and it's obviously a
volatile situation right that I mean I
don't I don't know how else to to put it
other than that okay but
ready
where you going bud come here come here
what come here stop walking
away stop walking away come here hands
out your pocket hands out your pocket
592 go like this you got anything on you
man no stop
[Applause]
running he running towards 114 regalia
white T-shirt red
shorts trying to get ped up right
now
go your face only if you like it though
that's the
question I'm going to get a female back
here well get
it just stay there just stay there I
want to take them off okay I want to be
my piss you wouldn't Tred me stay in the
blue box no hold on stay in the blue box
you you want to tase me no do it stay in
the blue box I like it kinky stay in the
blue box Grace stay in the blue box step
back you can touch me step back you
touch
me
just stay in that blue box look no no
you don't want me here you don't want me
[Music]
here stay in the blue box no get the
fuck me just stay there get
the you didn't catch my doctor you
didn't catch the person set me into
pieces you didn't catch them stay in the
blue box you didn't catch me me stay in
the BL box you didn't catch me and you
didn't catch them you go let people
slice and dice your community before you
let them connect the pieces just stay in
the blue box don't touch me she no I
don't need she she is ur
everywhere yes all in the back seat of
my car yes I did out disrespect him fuck
you want to take a test that's on no
fuck the time all right refusal I 198
right over here do you not understand
yeah I'm saying I got you I got it I'm
saying confessing to your piss T right I
understand do you want to say that I do
I got it but y'all didn't right I I got
you
NO3 no you don't I know no you don't no
you don't I got
you stand by for a minute hey hey come
stand right here at this window
hey how hey how how doing how you doing
can we clear the room this is Jennifer
Davis Hi hi Jennifer Jennifer how you
doing you so I we talked to Miss Davis a
little bit about some reports that we'
received as late as this morning um and
so she understands and and she said
she'd be willing to meet with you and
talk to you cor uh but we want to give
you all some privacy too so is this a
suitable we'll just step out here how
you doing there I'm good how are you
oh end of the week almost yes so what's
going on
today they said they had reports where I
was drinking at
school which is never
happened when was the last time you had
anything drink uh last night okay about
what time did you quit drinking uh
probably about 10:30 10:30 how much did
you
drink just a glass of wine and nothing
major okay all right all right well
would you be willing to submit to some
tests yeah to make sure everything's
okay
I don't even know what that
0.06 is
that you are just under the legal
limit so if you were to be out driving
right now you would be charged with DWI
driving while
intoxicated under the the legal limit
just under it the legal limit is
08 which is DUI the from a 06 to 107 you
can be charged with the ewi I
haven't had anything to drink
today again our our policy and
procedures stay anybody that goes into
back SE be yeah I'm going to do I'm
going to work with you a little bit okay
we remain calm we're get a hand cffe up
front do what P hand Coffey up front not
that's fine okay all
right all right go ahead and put your
hands in front of you with your thumbs
facing up please what is my I mean what
is my CH is this going to go like on the
news Mr Kenzie chances are it will
Jennifer I don't have control over what
they put on the news but there's a good
chance that once this gets reported then
there will be statements will will have
to release and notes will'll have to
send home to parents and then news
reporters will probably show
up uh I will be as discreet as I can in
in terms of how I handle it could we
please I've never been in trouble in my
life I understand but again that's not
not up to me I'm not going to go pushing
anything out there they show up that
happen okay you did not but we we got to
respond
and let people know that we followed our
policy and had to involve the police
department yeah
St turn around turn around chill chill I
a going to turn around
can I get my C on my my phone
please can I get my C don't
move female custody we're in the
department great job
stand
up lean to the right lean to the
right stand
up stand up for
me back here now they was in the front
by us she ran back
here
can I get my
inard as and we can go
[Applause]
back get on the ground on the fucking
ground on the ground now now on your
belly on your belly hands be on your
back
for
what huh why are you running cuz she was
running they were chasing her who's
chasing who the police CH so you just
start running yeah that's not how that
work that's not how it works
buddy um where's your car where's
where's your
car Katie can you bring our car over the
front for this
mail now all right you got to put them
in
here you have anything on you any
weapons I'm putting all
right where's the money at don't reach
don't reach don't reach for anything
dude4 you got weed on you can smell it I
a got weed on me you got it somewhere